[Aplausos]
[Música]
mira a la mujer que tienes a un lado
a la que te acompaña hoy podrías decir
que solamente con verla a los ojos es
una mujer feliz
en el 2014 según datos del inegi
solamente el 56 por ciento de las
mujeres mexicanas se sienten felices
yo formo parte de un grupo de 4.500
mujeres que radicamos en san luís potosí
o somos originarias de esta ciudad todas
somos muy diferentes tenemos diferencias
desde el largo de nuestro cabello la
zona en la ciudad de la que vivimos la
religión que profesamos el número de
hijos que tenemos la forma en que los
educamos unas optan por la disciplina
positiva y otras todavía confiar en el
poder de la chanca habemos solteras
casadas abuelas las chaparritas
las delgaditas las que creen que las
quesadillas solo son de queso y las que
tenemos la razón
en nuestro grupo todas somos diferentes
y es cierto hay un dicho popular que
dice mujeres juntas
andarán dos juntos si no estuvieran de
acuerdo
nosotros a pesar de las diferencias
cuando se trata de un bien común las
4500 mujeres que somos hoy somos una
sola
todos los días hacemos diferentes
actividades de manera virtual y física
que buscan que todas las mujeres que
forman parte de nuestra comunidad se
sepan amadas y respetadas
valoradas seguras valientes capaces que
nada ni nadie las puede detener
actividades virtuales tan simples como
contestar a una encuesta para saber cuál
es tu sabor favorito del helado
compartir un pedacito de la gran
historia que tienes de vida porque de
este modo seguramente habrá una
desconocida que pueda identificarse
contigo
contar cómo fue una experiencia de tus
hijos sentirte tentado por el nacimiento
de un bebé sentir que te gradúas con la
que vive enfrente cosas tan sencillas
como tener transmisiones en vivo con
expertas que nos hablan desde mecánica
salud mental disciplina positiva entre
muchas otras cosas
y actividades físicas que pueden ir
desde un simple desayuno con la vecina
que aún no conoces pero forma parte de
esta comunidad hasta fiestas clubes de
lectura tejido carreras muchísimas cosas
pero nuestro más grande motor son las
causas benéficas el libro con
traducciones y más vendido en la
historia mundial no nos deja opciones
nos dice ama a tu prójimo como a ti
mismo ve por la viuda aboga por el
huérfano no angustias al extranjero
acuérdate de los presos como si
estuvieras juntamente con ellos
es por eso que nosotras no tenemos
opción lo hemos tomado como nuestro
deber y como una obligación de esta
forma nos hemos involucrado con la casa
del migrante asilos de ancianos casa
sonar el albergue del hospital central
el instituto para ciegos y débiles
visuales del estado entre muchas otras
instituciones como aquellas que trabajan
con mujeres que son violentadas y sus
familias realizamos un proceso cada tres
meses que inicia eligiendo a una
institución asociación o grupo
vulnerable de nuestra ciudad esto para
entregarles una donación en especie
haciendo un proceso que durará un mes
completo iniciando con la
sensibilización de nuestros miembros
para que conozcan un poco de las
personas que la institución que hemos
elegido está atendiendo uno de las más
difíciles ha sido que nuestras mujeres
vean a las que están reclusas como lo
que son mujeres que tienen necesidades
tan básicas como tú o como yo de usar un
jabón
o una muda de ropa limpia lo mismo ha
sucedido para entender un poco de las
dificultades que viven los ciegos en las
calles de nuestra ciudad entender que
los migrantes a veces solo viajan con lo
que tienen puesto y nada más después de
la sensibilización de conocer un poco de
la institución y de sus directivos
comenzamos lanzando retos a nuestros
miembros en diferentes zonas de la
ciudad
son retos muy sencillos por ejemplo si
tu red de nuestro grupo
perdidamente enamorada de todas todas
entonces tendrás que donar una bolsa de
arroz
contrario estás
perdidamente enamorada de ironman
pero se pueden abstener entonces deberás
donar una presentas en tetra pak
condimentado así de sencillo y entonces
generamos un sentido de competencia pero
de unión entre una zona de la ciudad y
la otra el norte contacto el este contra
el oeste pero todas donando para una
misma causa
no importa civiles en lo más posibles en
pozos todas vamos a colaborar hacia la
misma causa
posteriormente
realizamos un picnic familiar en el que
todos tanto las mujeres los hijos los
esposos se involucran de la misma manera
que red en ser llevados también por
ellos o sea en este reto de los
superhéroes también invitamos a las
mujeres a que se disfrazarán es probable
que hayan robar máscara de ironman de
uno de sus hijos o que ha jugado un
mandil de la cocina para elaborar su
capa cosas así de simples los esposos
son quienes les toman la foto como
evidencia de que está cumpliendo con sus
retos y durante el picnic los donativos
que ya hemos juntado se clasifican se
separan se contactan para que ese mismo
día
traigan a la institución hemos entregado
en nuestra última causa un camión de
tres y media toneladas para una sola
casa hogar apoyando nosotros a dos
entregando equitativamente para ambas
casas
además realizamos subastas las uvas las
hemos sacado por parte de quienes
dirigimos
por parte de quienes dirigimos el
cuando escuchamos el concepto de subasta
a beneficio de simplemente lo primero
que tenga en mente sea una noche
elegante la gente cuando ropa muy fina
pujando para adquirir obras de arte
reconocidas o piezas de joyería muy fina
nosotras realizamos nuestras subastas
a cara lavada y con nuestra mejor pijama
de tal modo que tomamos donaciones de
nuestras miembros realizar subastas
cosas muy simples puede ser pisado
pay de queso hecho en casa 11 autolavado
su compramos que tomamos el país de
queso con un costo de 100 pesos
comenzaremos la puja en 50 pesos y así
iremos subiendo el reto consiste para
quienes dirigimos el grupo es que si de
esos 50 llegamos al 100 que es el costo
original nosotras
cumpliremos un reto cómo llegar nuestra
cara en el vídeo
si rebajamos ese costo entonces podremos
hacer una danza áfrica aunque no
tengamos ni la más remota idea de cómo
se reales
y si duplicamos el precio entonces
hablaremos por un buen rato con el
efecto que produce tragar helio de un
globo metálico
de esta forma así tan sencillo nuestras
amigas donan pagan y apoyamos una
institución por no decir que pagan por
vernos a hacer el ridículo
gracias a este tipo de cosas en este
reto que recaudamos en 15 minutos 2000
pesos para el albergue del hospital
central
en este tipo de retos nos ha permitido
adquirir
regletas y bastones para todos los
alumnos del instituto para ciegos y
débiles visuales adquirimos 80 piezas de
mudas de ropa y sandalias para las
reclusas en la pila además de entregar
las sandalias para los los reos que son
adultos mayores son inimputables esto
quiere decir que tienen alguna
discapacidad
hemos entregado cámaras para
instituciones que elaboran con mujeres
víctimas de violencia y sus familias
lavadoras para una casa hogar salas para
otras y todo gracias a pegar la cara del
vidrio
así es como trabajamos cada tres meses
elegimos una institución el día de hoy
estamos concluyendo en favor de
fundación inclusión autismo y bueno yo
te dije cómo hacemos para que la mujer
se sienta feliz porque creemos que
cuando una mujer se siente motivada se
siente capaz de enseñar o de aprender de
otras para sentirse empoderada esta
felicidad que nos genera el dar es más
bienaventurado que recibir este pan que
arroja sobre las aguas muy pronto
regresará a nosotros
esta felicidad que se genera en la mujer
por ende se va a contagiar en su familia
y se verá reflejada en la sociedad en la
que vivimos
nuevamente te invito a que mires a la
mujer que está a tu lado
yo ya te dije que hacemos para que
nuestras mujeres se sientan felices
mira esa mujer y comprométete hoy a
hacer algo porque ella a través de ti se
sienta feliz muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]